foreign
Justin is with us in Corpus Christi hi
Justin welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey Dave good to talk to you
and are you still doing better than you
deserve always better than I deserve
brother what's up
um just
a little short back story with after I
left my mom and just after Christmas of
um her life insurance that redeemed was
400 000 and after I paid the funeral and
her expenses it was enough to get me out
of debt so I finished baby step three
back in about six weeks ago actually
and honestly Dave um well at this point
I'm
bluntly I'm scared I have lived my
entire life broke I was broke the day I
was born because I'm I'm the only child
of a single parent my mom we lived in
poverty my entire childhood so this is
unknown worse than me if you know what
I'm saying
I don't I don't have the income to buy a
house right now so I'm just curious I've
always seen YouTube videos that oh
babysat 3B is supposed to say 20 for a
house but
um 42 single unattached no kids no media
family we don't need to buy a house
right now what um
you got 400 Grand
and I'm sorry
uh 100
000 100 okay and you paid the funeral
and you paid off how much debt
uh 48k in student loans I paid my car
off which was another nine thousand
another 20 grand in Old medical and
credit cards it took me about eight
months to find a mall and pay them all
okay how much money are you getting how
much money do you have left
um in my savings I have ten thousand
that's my that's my full funded
emergency fund okay and everything and
you're 100 debt free and that's all you
ended up with Okay good all right I got
the picture I'd like to call it that was
the last getting on Main tell me because
I told her about you and and during 2020
I was trying to get on the path and she
said yeah that sounds great go for it
and if anything this was the last gift
to me it was hey get out of debt I'm
sorry sorry that's the way you got it
I'm glad it worked out good for you
um what what do you do what's your
income
it's a restaurant assistant general
manager I make about 33
.
um so what are your career aspirations
what are you gonna do with your life man
you're 48. you did you say you're 48.
I'm 42 42. okay
so what are you going to be doing when
you're 52 that's so much more exciting
and cool than what you're doing now
truthfully I haven't thought about that
I've been so focused on trying to be the
best leader I can because I've worked
with a lot of teenagers I need to set a
good example for them I wasn't
suggesting you abandon your job I just
asked you what you were going to become
hopefully you become a GM okay I like
the place I like the place I work at I
work I like the people I work with and
okay what is it what does a GM make
I believe because my old one just
resigned we're getting a new one next
week
um 48 .
okay I think so I I obviously never told
me my salary but they get a base salary
they they're only they're the only ones
on salary and then they get a bonus
based on the monthly business how much
the business does each month okay
all right good all right so we got a
plan that's good and why is it you don't
want to own a house
I just feel like it's a little
Superfluous specific I'm sorry
superflers because I don't have a why
for kids I mean it's just me I live in a
one bedroom that's within my budget I
pay
669 employment plus utilities I'm
comfortable
but at the same time I've seen some of
your old YouTube videos where I mean I
don't want to be stagnant I mean I want
to keep moving but yep honestly I don't
know the direction to move well there is
part of this that you're looking at the
Here and Now 42 years old right now
you're unattached maybe in five or ten
years you won't be you know you there's
this piece of this puzzle that's an
unknown and you kind of have to think
through that you have to look at your
future the same way Dave asks you hey
what do you want to be doing in five
years what do you want to be doing in 10
years you have to ask yourself about
your life in general what do you want it
to look like we've seen how this money
that your mom left whether it's through
Insurance how it's changed your life
right so you have the ability to do that
same thing in some way right there's a
purpose there is still a purpose for you
regardless if you have a wife and kids
and that purpose can have Financial
attachments to it but more than that we
know that homeownership is a part of
Building Wealth and even if you don't
want to buy a home right now I do think
it's something that you should and can
aspire to
um with your income living in Corpus
Christi I think it's still something
that you can have I just think it's
something you're not used to like you
said you're not used to
where you're at financially and so you
don't know what it looks like to really
prosper in and of your own right on your
own and so it's like I've never seen
that before I don't well let's just stay
where we are I'm comfortable here
mentally and in every other way but I
would challenge you to move past that
and really dream beyond that because
that's what you're headed for yeah
that's good
and Justin on the on the logical side of
the economic side let's work through
that for a second
short-term renting is not a problem
long-term renting is a problem and
here's why it's a problem
the property that you're living in is
going to go up in value in the next 10
years substantially
and the landlord is going to benefit
from that not you
so if you live in a property in Corpus
Christi let's say you bought a
two-bedroom condo okay is similar to
what you're in now and you paid 150 000
for it okay let's just make that up I
just made that up all right and then in
10 years that thing's worth 250.
and and you don't you lose that hundred
grand an increase in value
because you didn't own it the second
thing that we know is 100 of the time
over a 10-year period of time rents go
up
when you buy a condo at 150 and your
payment is 1100 bucks or whatever it is
your payment does not go up so what
you've done is the largest line item in
your budget is housing and you have
stabilized it into the future when you
buy you're locking it in into the future
when you buy by not locking it in you're
a hundred percent guaranteed your
largest line item is going to go up I
mean you're 42 think about when you were
32 what rent was
you know I'm 62. my rent when I was 22
was 235 dollars
for a one bedroom
that Sharon and I moved into after we
got married I mean that's hard to even
grasp in today you know 41 years later
right
very very hard to even get my head
around that because you can't even walk
on the property now for 235 dollars I
mean it's just you know but but uh and
so you think about over the scope of my
life like 40 years where's your rent
gonna be it's gonna be 235 versus
1235 today and you know 100 of the time
that largest line item is going up when
you're a permanent renter so you are
always paying more and someone else is
benefiting from the increases in value
not you so short term I'm all about
renting when you're broke you should
rent until you get yourself straightened
out don't buy a house just because
buying a house is a good thing because
it's not a good thing when you're broke
but long-term home ownership stabilizes
your largest line item in your budget
locks in your monthly cost to a fixed
amount and you have this large asset
that is going up in value these are two
Wonder careful personal financial
benefits to home ownership so plan on in
the next 12 to 18 months finding you a
little condo to buy doesn't have to be
anything fancy right we're not asking to
go crazy and you don't have to mow grass
I don't care you know if I'm you I'm not
mowing grass I'd get a condo you know
this I
it doesn't matter if you have kids it
doesn't have no matter if you have a
wife oh that that that all applies
period future future financial planning
is important for everybody it's really
the moral of the story yeah and and if
you buy a condo in five years from now
you your whole life changes and you sell
it you're gonna make money on it yeah
you know so just pick a good one in a
good neighborhood something solid
conservative and not straining you and
stabilize that line item in your budget
this is the Ramsey Show